[Musique]
nous sommes le 8 mai 2010 est emmanuel
macron a été élu président de la
république hier soir bienvenue pour
cette édition spéciale sur tv fil 78
nous allons revenir sur les résultats
dans ce département des yvelines et sur
les principales réactions
emmanuel macron large vainqueur dans les
yvelines +2 77% pour le leader du
mouvement en marche nous étions avec les
militants à versailles au moment de
l'annoncé des résultats a du côté du
front national on analyse encore les
derniers chiffres la progression par
rapport au premier tour n'est que de 50
mille voix le fn ne parvient pas à
l'emporter dans sa commune de mantes la
ville mais s'impose donc plusieurs
villages dans la 8e circonscription
notamment et puis et quels sont les
enseignements de cette élection
présidentielle en vue des législatives
de juin difficile à prédire avec l
élimination dès le premier tour et des
partis traditionnels nous ferons malgré
tout un point plus particulièrement dans
la sixième circonscription et en plateau
pour nous accompagner au cours de la
prochaine demi heure aziz françois
n'diaye bonsoir que soit responsable
départemental en marche face à vous les
journalistes de tv fils nicolas qui rit
le 800 ma longueur des bons soirs avant
le résultat est définitif au niveau
national le voici 66,10 % des suffrages
pour emmanuel macron aziz françois à
votre sentiment c'est une victoire nette
pas de triomphalisme pour autant on sent
tout de même que le président a pris la
mesure aussi de ce qu'on appelle le vote
par défaut
les électeurs ne s'y retrouvent pas mais
ont choisi de me soutenir oui parce que
dès lors que nous avions un candidat
d'extrême droite au second tour il était
convenu que les choses étaient
différents et il y avait quasiment pas
de suspens par rapport au 1er tour vous
l'a véritablement il y avait un vrai
enjeu là il s'agissait de plus tôt
rassemblée et surtout éviter tout
triomphalisme quand on sait que beaucoup
de voix venait
autre candidat et surtout là-bas on voit
manuel macro justement arriver où
l'ouvrier à soir on va l'écouter
justement juste avant cette arrivée au
lourd
sa première réaction après l'annoncé des
résultats acte et je sais les divisions
de notre nation qui ont conduit certains
à des votes extrêmes je les respecte je
sais la colère l'anxiété les doutes
qu'une grande partie d'entre vous ont
aussi exprimé il est de ma
responsabilité de les entendre en
protégeant les plus fragiles en
organisant mieux les solidarités en
luttant contre toutes les formes
d'inégalités ou de discrimination en
assurant de manière implacable est
résolu votre sécurité
les attentes sont grandes on sent qu
emmanuel macron apprend la mesure en
tout cas je le disais à tant de grandes
c'est à dire qu'en cas d'échec on entend
déjà des voix s'élever à dire que c'est
une victoire assurée pour le front
national dans cinq ans bien avant bien
avant même la nature de cette victoire
nous savions et je pense que tous on
avait pris conscience dès le soir du
premier tour qu'il s'agissait
aujourd'hui d'une configuration de
nouvelles et que quel que soit le
candidat qui serait élu si cette fois ci
ça ne marche pas au prochain tour on
risquait d'avoir de belles surprises
avec un front national ou en tout cas
l'extrême droite qui soit très dessus au
dessus de ce qu'on pouvait attendre
donc l'enjeu nous le savions aujourd'hui
ça c'est effectivement de porter ce que
nous sommes mais là dessus je ne
m'inquiète pas parce que vous savez dès
la création du mouvement
nous avions nous appeler à un grand
rassemblement des progressistes et c'est
quelque chose qui est dans notre adn
donc c'est en tout cas aucun scrupule et
sans calcul tactique que nous assumons
aujourd'hui ce cet appel vous restez
avec nous pour commenter réagir les
différents résultats des yvelines que
nous allons regarder donc analyser
ensemble quelques instants quelques
réactions politiques de figure dans le
département écoutez pierre bédier tout
d'abord le président des yvelines le
score dans les
et tout à fait remarquable pour renvoyer
madame le pen à ses études et elle en a
bien besoin
bon et maintenant on commence une autre
étape
c'est celle des élections législatives
hélène nécessité de constituer une
majorité pour soutenir un gouvernement
qui soit réformiste mais réaliste
donc c'est un gouvernement qui ne sera
pas anti macron mais qui rééquilibrera
les insuffisances de monsieur macro à
noter que gérard larcher le président du
sénat membre des républicains estiment
que la droite et le centre ont contribué
à la victoire d'emmanuel macron et s'est
exprimé à ce sujet dès hier soir quant à
valérie pécresse la présidente de la
région ile de france elle aussi des
républicains estiment qu emmanuel macron
à gagner sur une certaine forme
d'ambiguïté que ces réformes n'ont pas
l'audace suffisante pour sortir la
france du fléau du chômage et puis
j'ajoute également que christine boutin
conseillère départementale qui a appelé
à voter marine le pen pendant
l'entre-deux-tours
elle s'est exprimée via twitter je cite
campagne 2010 est pourri nous rentrons
dans l'ère du big brother orwell avait
raison
liberté chérie où es-tu fin de citation
nous allons donc à présent nous
concentrer sur les résultats dans les
yvelines avec ce résultat pour le
département des yvelines vous allez le
voir la victoire d'emmanuel macron est
encore plus net 77,15 % en progression
de 2 190 mille voix par rapport au
premier tour dans notre département
aziz françois le report a été bon
l'abstention et même un peu plus faible
qu'au niveau national
23 août à 2 25% on va revenir sur
l'abstention tout à l'heure néanmoins
bon report de voix et ben on assiste
peut-être même pour la suite pour les
législatives
oui surtout formidable mobilisation de
la part de nos équipes partout nous
avions fait le soin d'aller partout
effectivement et la droite et la gauche
mélenchon et ça avait fait de bons
scores pour appeler nos concitoyens à
soutenir se moque
macron et je suis notamment d'autant
plus ravi que son intérêt nous n'avons
pas reçu véritablement de soutien des
équipes des appareils en tout cas de la
vallée de la gauche il a fallu faire le
travail tout seul et avec beaucoup de
détermination
donc aujourd'hui c'est une grande
satisfaction surtout pour nos équipes
qui ont vraiment tout donné sur le
terrain et la nuit a été courte pour
vous vous allez fêter la victoire hier
soir du côté de versailles notamment au
qg versailles et que j'ai yvelinois nous
étions et sur place nicolas landry pour
ce reportage
[Applaudissements]
les premières estimations sont tombés
emmanuel macron vient d'être élu
président de la république
il obtient plus de 65 % des voix la fête
peut commencer pour les militants
yvelinois du mouvement en marche on est
euphorique
c'est génial c'est vraiment c'est pas
marine le pen qui bat c on a una contre
loges le fascisme entre guillemets on
est super content
[Musique]
les compétences travailleurs mais versés
soit la prime est parti de rien il est
devenu président nouveau là je suis ravi
de l'espoir qui portent question d'unité
un espoir que des bandes aussi l'europe
dans les yvelines le candidat en marche
obtient plus de 77% des suffrages
un meilleur score qu'au niveau national
que l'on retrouve aussi à montigny le
bretonneux
avec près de 84% des voix de quoi
satisfaire les marcheurs pour leur
mobilisation très très fort ce qui a pu
se faire on a travaillé très dur mais
surtout quand je pense à tous ces
bénévoles qui nous ont suivis par un des
premiers jours qui ont cru en nous et
qui sont battus partout aujourd'hui hier
encore on était est ce qu a réalisé
emmanuel macron c'est justement de
permettre un bon français de croire en
nous et de re croire dans cette belle
dame qu'est la cinquième régulier et
d'aller à la soupe ou une révolution
démocratique
certains militants quittent rapidement
le qg yvelinois direction l'esplanade du
louvre pour célébrer ce moment inédite
dans l'histoire de la vème république un
candidat élu président en ayant créé son
mouvement politique il est un peu plus
d'un an
tout le monde nous disait que c'était
impossible
melvin ne connaissez pas la france
[Applaudissements]
merci de votre confiance
merci du temps que vous avez donnée
merci de votre engagement à toutes et
tous des remerciements destiné notamment
aux militants du modem
durant la campagne il se sont engagés
aux côtés d' emmanuel macron notamment
dans les yvelines
mais le soutien du modem reste plein et
entier au bien au contraire on est plus
motivé que jamais pour l'aider à réussir
son projet entre les candidats en marché
des candidats modem avant cette alliance
pour les législatives des postes
ministériels pourraient être attribués à
des membres du modem
emmanuel macron devrait dévoiler le nom
de son premier ministre et la
composition du gouvernement
lundi 15 mai on vient d'entendre le
responsable du modem dans le département
par ailleurs conseiller régional
également bruno myle jens est
aujourd'hui un allié à cette formation
centriste allié incontournable
oui un allié précieux aussi parce qu'il
a été à nos côtés pendant toute cette
période où nous avons fait campagne sur
le terrain ensemble ni toutes ces
équipes et je voulais saluer ici parce
qu'effectivement tout ça s'est fait dans
un très bon esprit et nous avons pu dès
le lendemain de cette alliance former un
nouveau groupe qui a su sur le terrain
agir dans le seul intérêt de notre
candidat on va parler des législatives
tout à l'heure mais on peut imaginer
comme l'a laissé entendre bonhommes il y
aura des des candidatures communes des
anciens candidats modem qui partiront
sous l'étiquette en marche
oui parce qu'aujourd'hui ce qui compte
je le disais c'est avoir une alliance la
plus large possible
nous avons commencé effectivement avec
le modem mais la vocation elle est
beaucoup plus loin à intégrer des gens
de la société civile des noms de la
liste de la droite et de la gauche
classique
ce que nous ne voulons pas ce sont les
accords d'appareil aujourd'hui il faut
ouvrir vraiment la vie démocratique
française à toutes celles et ceux qui
ont qui a une vocation et qui aspire à
construire un vaste rassemblement pour
faire un vrai changement un vrai
une vraie rupture une rupture
démocratique donc c'est pour ça que le
modem était un allié précieux pour
montrer que c'était possible car
n'oublions pas c'était pas gagné au
départ je disais la nuit a été courte
pour vous mais j'imagine que vous avez
d'ores et déjà regarder un peu les
résultats on va les revoir ses résultats
quelques-uns en tout cas je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez les retrouver
sur notre site internet notre
application mobile notamment les
résultats concernant saint quentin en
yvelines quelques communes plus de 84% à
montigny le bretonneux la plus de 83% à
voisins le bretonneux 82% à la verrière
est ce qu'il ya des communes que vous
avez analysé regarder avec un oeil plus
attentif que que d'autres quelques
communes plus attentivement que d'autres
quasiment tout parce que quand on l'a
quand on a fait notre première analyse
avant le premier tour on s'est rendu
compte que là les poches d'un dc-10
partout dans le département
donc à partir de ce moment-là nous
aimons nous et qui ont dit qu'il fallait
pas faire de calculs et qu'il fallait
faire quasi du tout azimut est allé
partout donc nos équipes se sont
mobilisées
nous avons eu plus de deux mille
marcheurs qui ont été sur le terrain et
dans toutes les communes depuis
retranché même pour avoir un seul but
parler aux citoyens
vous savez à partir non vous avez un
échange avec le citoyen vous avez
beaucoup plus de chances de le
convaincre
plutôt que de se cantonner à distribuer
des tracts ou de coller des affiches
donc ce travail de terrain là qui est un
petit peu la marque de fabrique dans
marche a fini par payer pourrait aussi
citer la ville de versailles j'aimerais
juste qu'on voit ce résultat parce que
françois fillon dans cette commune était
arrivé très largement en tête presque
50% des suffrages exprimés
et là on voit qu emmanuel macron fait 76
%
c'est inespéré sur versailles ces noces
de platine et inespéré parce que c'est
une des villes qui dès le début avait
accroché à la dynamique en marche et
nous avons beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
deux adhérents issus l'issue de cette
ville et je salue d'ailleurs le travail
qui est fait par didier baichère qui est
un de nos soutiens de la première heure
et qui fait un travail remarquable pour
essayer de rassurer et de montrer que
effectivement de versailles est un enjeu
qui n'a pas vocation à rester à droite
versailles
aujourd'hui à une sociologie qui change
une population qui évolue qui se
rajeunit et que en ce sens là je pense
que la position centrale que nous avons
peut être un atout voilà vous êtes déjà
en campagne pour les législatives on l'a
bien compris si on écoute attentivement
ce que vous dites
du côté du front national du côté des
perdants le front national c'est un peu
moins de 30 4% donc sur le résultat hier
soir on n'est pas loin des 40% a annoncé
ce plafond vers une nouvelle fois
nicolas dans les yvelines le résultat
est plus faible encore pour la formation
de marine le pen
oui en effet wilfried le front national
ne dépasse pas la barre des 23 % sur le
département même dans la seule mairie fn
d'ile-de-france à mantes-la-ville marine
le pen réalise un score inférieur à sa
performance nationale 31,96 % avec plus
de 33 % d'abstention donc que marine le
pen n'a pas réussi à mobiliser sur ce
terreau et idéologique du front national
sur l'ensemble du département le fn pour
ce second tour rassemble près de cent
cinquante mille bulletins exprimés soit
51 mille de plus qu'il ya deux semaines
est aussi beaucoup plus qu'il y avait 15
ans en 2002 jean marie le pen avait
réuni au second tour 94 mais le voit sur
sa candidature progression donc pour le
fn dans les yvelines mais trop peu
encore écouter le secrétaire
départemental du parti
nous avons toujours été en difficulté
sur les yvelines on a un électorat qui
qui hésitent au changement et donc on a
véritablement cette perception de
poursuivre dans la continuité de
protection des même si c'est tout à fait
illusoire mais je pense que c'est ça qui
a voulu jouer sur cet électorat
yvelinois et
le report de voix des fillonistes
suspense a été insuffisant trop faible
parce que justement il y avait cette
crainte
à nous donc de rassurer et convaincre
les personnes qui sont accrus aussi
parce qu'elle a beaucoup et si on
resserre à présent sur saint quentin en
yvelines sur l'agglomération le score de
marine le pen est encore inférieure aux
scores départementale marine le pen est
en dessous des 20% vous le voyez avec un
total de 19 1286 voit précisément elle
réalise son meilleur score à coignières
avec 24 13% des suffrages pire score à
montigny le bretonneux la ville la plus
peuplée d'ailleurs c'est à noter avec 15
84% pour marine le pen
attention là aussi c'est comme pour le
reste du département le fn fait sur
chacune des douze communes plus qu'il y
a à 15 ans donc c'est à relativiser
évidemment pour le front national lors
de l'accession au second tour de jean
marie le pen face à jacques chirac on
s'en souvient en 2002 alors il y ait une
autre interrogation derrière ce résultat
du front national c'est l'avenir aussi
de debout la france nicolas dupont
aignan avait décidé de s'allier avec
marine le pen et oui et c'est finalement
l'autre grand perdant de ce second tour
de l'élection présidentielle le parti de
nicolas dupont aignan pour l'instant
debout la france souhaite s'inscrire
dans l'opposition emmanuel macron et
aucun d'accord aucun accord et est prévu
en tout cas pour le moment pour le fn
pour l'avenir écouté debout la france
veut participer à une vraie
reconstitution de la droite républicaine
et patriotes et pense en être même la
clé de voûte parce que justement nous
sommes le poil équilibre de toute cette
droite entre la droite issu du front
national et du rassemblement le marine
et des autres républicains qui ne se
sont pas retrouvés dans le parti dit les
républicains c'est pas une alliance de
partis
c'était un accord de gouvernement nous
en sommes toujours au même point est bon
ça pas marché aussi bien qu'on pense à
moi peur vous me donnez une métaphore
rugbystique cette année ça n'a pas été
transformé alors à noter que certains
accords pourraient être tout de même
conclu il finit entre le fn et debout la
france pour éviter de faire doublon sur
certaines circonscriptions ce sera
notamment le cas c'est sûr sur une
circonscription sur les 12 2
des yvelines les détails pour les deux
parties seront connues d'ici une semaine
maximum
merci nicolas l'inconnu sur ce scrutin
du second tour c'était aussi la
participation ou l'abstention comment
les votes des socialistes des
républicains encore des partisans de
jean-luc mélenchon allait se reporter
bien dans les yvelines l'abstention est
plus faible que dans le reste de la
france à 23 2 68% contre 25,44 on a
mieux voter et puis le nombre de
bulletins blancs et nuls aussi
sensiblement moindres dans notre
département
quoi qu'il en soit à 6 francs soit dans
les yvelines où que ce soit dans la
totalité de la france il ya plus de 10 %
de bulletins des électeurs qui ne se
sont pas exprimés finalement blancs nuls
abstentions c'est inquiétant c'est très
inquiétant parce que c'est un moment de
démocratie qu'il ne fallait pas rater
et c'est toujours malheureux quand on
voit que démocratie recule et ce qui m'a
effectivement beaucoup peiné c'est d'une
part le non choix de jean-luc mélenchon
qui fait vraiment le sait a été un des
plus virulents combattants des fn et
qu'il a subitement a été fortement
amnésique dessous tout ce travail au
point de mettre à prix égal les
maquereaux et et marine le pen
c'est malheureux le trophée majeur et
votre reportage le dit si bien c'est
l'attitude de l'ue pour n'ayant qui est
incompréhensible parce que lui qui se
disait gaulliste quand on sait que le
gaulliste s'est construit sucre il vole
isme s'est construit sur un nom un non
au fascisme est lui arrivé à franchir
cette ligne jaune qui consistait à faire
une alliance avec un parti d'extrême
droite
c'est très troublant et avec tout cela
je le contexte je comprends que certains
n'ai pas eu envie d'aller voter pour
cette question participation je vous
propose aussi de regarder ces chiffres
pour voir la participation dans les
yvelines l'abstention plutôt dans les
yvelines et on voit que c est l'absent
sur la pire sur les derniers scrutins en
2002 18,04 % des électeurs s'étaient
abstenus là nous sommes à 23 68 % est ce
qui est aussi une difficulté
supplémentaire pour le nouveau président
élu alors puisqu'on parle d'abstention
de report des voix prenons un exemple
une commune celle des clayes-sous-bois
jean luc mélenchon françois fillon
avaient totalisé chacun près de 20%
marine le pen avait terminé à
la quatrième place comment tout cela
s'est il reporter nicolas landry
emmanuel macron arrive en tête aux
clayes-sous-bois avec un peu plus de 76%
des voix
marine le pen réalise l'un de ses
meilleurs scores sur saint quentin en
yvelines avec plus de 23 5% des
suffrages le candidat en marche a
bénéficié du report des voix notamment
avec une partie de l'électorat de
françois fillon et de jean luc mélenchon
il avait enregistré chacun un résultat
autour des 20% au premier tour cette
élection est particulière parce que je
pense que beaucoup de candidats certain
nombre de candidats qui ont voté par une
éviction et pas par conviction il y en a
qui se sont abstenus quand même voter
front national dans la commune
l'abstention dépasse les 23 %
autre conséquence de ce rejet les votes
blancs ou nuls qui représente 10% des
votants et certains personnalisent leur
bulletin en souhaitant envoyer un
message
la colère il ya du mécontentement il ya
du désespoir aussi il ya une défiance
défiance vis-à-vis des politiques
donc c'est pas du désintérêt je pense
qu'elle beaucoup de il ya beaucoup d
espoir dans ce dance est dans cette
situation qu'on connaît actuellement
prochain rendez vous électoral avec les
législatives les 11 et 18 juin prochain
un scrutin crucial pour former une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale
quels enseignements pour les
législatives dans le département à des
yvelines l'enjeu pour le mouvement en
marche qui devient maintenant à un parti
politique en pleine mesure c'est
d'obtenir cette majorité absolue est ce
que c'est possible si tout à fait
possible je pense que les français nous
ont donné aujourd'hui des mines majorité
à ce vote il s'agit maintenant de
concrétiser de confirmer lors de ces
législatives il s'agit aujourd'hui de
remplir le contrat que nous avions eue
dès le départ et que emmanuel macron a
si bien incarnée en proposant un contrat
avec la nationale avec la nation ce
contrat il inclut aussi l'avènement de
nouvelles têtes l'avènement de nouveaux
visages qui puisse incarner cette
nouvelle politique
mais ce n'est pas la même chose si on va
dire parce que finalement les électeurs
qui sont portés sur un manuellement
vont pas forcément se porter sur un
candidat inconnu sur une circonscription
pour devenir député et qui sera en
concurrence avec des figures locales des
gens qui ont fait leurs preuves aussi
tout à fait mais ce sera l'enjeu que
nous avons nous en tout cas échéant
marche a relevé le ce sera le défi que
nous aurons à relever
et dès demain nous allons déjà présenté
nos candidats dans les jours qui
viennent et aussi leur expliquer que
aujourd'hui quand vous êtes député vous
êtes député de la nation pas d'une
circonscription de local et qu' il
s'agit d'intégrer une politique et une
vision globale qu'il va falloir assumer
appliquer celles qui émanent de la
proposer il y aura douze candidats dans
l'es12 circonscription des yvelines
oui complètement nos candidats sont
partout en france pas seulement dans les
yvelines
nous aurons les 577 candidats toutes
parts à l'avancé quels objectifs dans
les yvelines
quittant la lavandière neuf
circonscriptions disent qu'ils sont
détenus par par les républicains et leur
hargne et lui dit et il y en a deux
trois qui sont détenus par les
socialistes je pense qu'on peut en avoir
au moins la moitié
vous pensez pouvoir faire basculer lors
du scrutin
alors écoutez sophie primas à ce sujet
c'est la secrétaire départementale des
républicains je le rappelais les
républicains qui sont majoritaires dans
ce département
bien sûr il ya des inquiétudes on a lu
les résultats du premier tour on regarde
les résultats du deuxième tour peut-être
avec un oeil différent mais les premiers
tours évidemment sont son porteur de
beaucoup d'enseignements on reste
évidemment dans une logique de
partenariat avec lui des é
le parti démocrate chrétien dans les
accords qui étaient les accords jusqu'à
présent effectivement bénéficier de la
10e circonscription qui est le fief de
jean frédéric poisson
bon moi je suis un peu chagriné quand
même par le nombre de candidatures
dissidentes du parti démocrate chrétien
qui qui fleurissent sur les îles je m'en
suis ouvert avec jean frédéric à jean
frédéric poisson mais je pense que ça
fera l'objet de discussions futures
le risque donc à droite c'est à la
division également du côté des
socialistes du côté de la gauche écouter
à présent la secrétaire départementale
du parti socialiste sandrine d'un gang
un programme à défendre des valeurs à
défendre qui dans bien des domaines ne
correspondent pas à ce sur quoi emmanuel
macron été élu et on voit d'ailleurs
qu'une partie de son électorat même au
premier tour à bâle un vote d'adhésion
c'était plutôt un vote par défaut
donc il ya vraiment à déterminer
maintenant une ligne politique et ce
sera les élections législatives qui
permettront de déterminer cette ligne
politique
donc nous on est sûr défense ce que sont
nos valeurs de gauche je solidarité de
partage aussi d'égalité donc
positionnera sur ces thèmes là et cette
union à gauche olivier paréja
responsable départemental europe
écologie et les verts entend bien
réussir à la celle et écoutez le de
toute façon c'est assez clair dans les
yvelines si la gauche veut régler tes au
second tour des législatives il n'y a
pas d'autre solution que de partir à
tomber après est extrêmement difficile
d'arriver à à trouver une façon de se
rassembler et il faudrait qu'on arrive
et c'est pas gagné a dépassé un petit
peu un peu les querelles de partis pour
arriver à faire un rassemblement on s'y
emploie mais ça va être ça va être très
compliqué pour terminer cette édition
spéciale sur tv fils focus à présent sur
la 11e circonscription des yvelines avec
vous haussmann et cette confirmation ce
matin à notre micro benoît hamon sera
bien candidat à l'élection législative
et oui le malheureux candidat du parti
socialiste à arrivé cinquième au premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle avec
6,36 % des voix et donc candidat à sa
réélection sur la 11e circonscription et
il n'aura pas la tâche facile en il faut
le savoir dans son fief attrape le
candidat est arrivé deuxième avec 24,23
% au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle devancé par jean luc
mélenchon à 32,62 malgré cela le
candidat se dit confiant et mettra en
avant ses actions sur la circonscription
ils me connaissent bien savent que
je suis un homme honnête loyal très
engagé j'ai beaucoup travaillé pour
cette circonscription pour tout le
canton de saint cyr comme le canton de
trappes elancourt le mesnil la verrière
j'ai travaillé pour ce canton pour les
habitants de ce canton et de cette
circonscription basse et attend pour
laquelle je me représente avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé et beaucoup de force et
de la force il lui en faudra le maire
d'elancourt jean michel fourgous ou est
lui aussi conquérir le siège de député
en poste que le candidat investi par les
républicains a bien connu en effet il a
été député de la 11e de 1995 à 2002 et
de 2007 à 2012 avant de perdre face à
benoît hamon jean michel fourgous veut
mettre l'accent sur l'emploi la sécurité
et l'éducation pour lui le bilan de
benoît hamon c'est je cite plus de
chômeurs et le fiasco des nouveaux
rythmes scolaires
ambiance jean michel fourgous qui n'a
pas souhaité aujourd'hui s'exprimer
devant nos caméras il attend à les
consignes recommandations de sa
formation politique et il y en ad'autres
un des candidats sur sept et 11e
circonscription il y a tout d'abord la
candidate du front national matip de
andrew hayes c'est la première fois que
la conseil régional ile-de-france du fn
se présentent sur 7 certes inscriptions
même si marine le pen n'a fait que 24
ans 11% des bois dans ce conte dans ce
canton contre 79,9 % pour emmanuel
macron la candidate compte bien profiter
de l'effet présidentielle écoutez là les
chats qui s'est vraiment pouvoir fait la
continuation de l'élection
présidentielle dans le sens où là on est
dans une élection nationale et on aurait
tort de s'arrêter au juste aux
considérations locales
le but du jeu étant de pour nous
de former cette réelle opposition qui
s'est incarné hier enfin dans ce face à
face
donc oui le but du jeu étant de montrer
que le camp des patriotes est là et bien
présent et est la seule véritable
opposition
le schip accroc noter que sur cette
circonscription c'est à saint cyr que le
front national fait son meilleur score
avec 23 points 66 % des voix autres
candidats qui devraient être investis
dans les prochains jours s'il vient
quand alou pis pour debout la france
la présidente d'honneur du parti dans
les yvelines n'en n'est pas à son
premier essai elle s'était déjà présenté
en 2012 et avait récolté 0 68% des bois
merci haussmann et on note aussi un quai
le modem le parti communiste aussi
devrait présenter des candidats on en
saura plus à la fin du dépôt des
candidatures en préfecture ce sera le 19
mai et puis il ya le mouvement marche
aussi et j'imagine que cette
circonscription
vous l'avez regarder en détail vous avez
des noms déjà en tête plus quand est non
pas encore nous allons communiquer là
dessus
dans quelques jours mais effectivement
c'est un enjeu très important que nous
regardons avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'intérêt parce que je pense que c'est
un des échecs de
du candidat sortant effectivement
aujourd'hui dans cette circonscription
on retrouve d'énormes difficultés
on le rappelle trap est la ville qui a
connu le plus de départs en syrie ce qui
prouve de la situation catastrophique et
la capacité à pouvoir relever les défis
qui sont là alors que nous connaissons
un département quand même assez prospère
donc nous nous mettrons nous aurons à
coeur en tout cas de mettre un candidat
qui soit de nature à venir un petit peu
bouleversé la donne car il ya des
victoires qui sont plus significatifs
d'autres donc on imagine que si benoît
hamon venait d'être battu par un
candidat en mars la victoire n'en serait
que plus belle pour vous on l'a bien
compris à vous écouter merci d'être
venus en plateau à 6 françois n'diaye
moore commenter ses résultats au
lendemain de l'élection à la présidence
de la république d'emmanuel macron merci
également aux mânes et un nicolas les
résultats sont à retrouver sur notre
site internet sur notre application
mobile et les réseaux sociaux
elle nous nous retrouverons aussi très
bientôt puisque la campagne des
législatives et des buts et elle sera à
suivre sur tv fil avec un dispositif
spécial à cette occasion à bientôt
[Musique]